according to Judaism who is God
it's difficult because Judaism like any
tradition that is thousands of years old
and encompasses so many different lands
and languages and thinkers
um it doesn't give a single answer to
even simple questions and to large
questions it certainly doesn't give a
single answer although Judaism was
responsible for introducing the
monotheistic idea to the world it
doesn't mean that it's one idea
so if you take maimonides the greatest
Sage
in the Jewish tradition
um medieval philosopher he would say
that God is an omnipotent benevolent
intangible
unimaginable God in fact he said you
can't say what God is only what God is
not because you have to emphasize could
talk more about that but basically you
have to emphasize the unknowability of
God
you have a modern philosopher like hesho
who says that God is a god of pathos a
god of deep feeling which probably would
make maimonides shiver if he heard such
a description and if you look in the
Bible God is always regretting or having
human emotions so there are so many
different kinds of depictions and ideas
and there is this tremendous tension
between Transcendence and imminence that
is in the Jewish tradition God God is
exquisitely close God is imminent
in the talmud's words God is as close as
your mouth is to your ear
um in other words whatever you say God
hears it and yet at the same time God is
unfathomably distant sometimes when I
speak to high schoolers I will say in
the Jewish tradition think of it this
way
when you were two years old you had no
idea what it was to be a 15 year old not
only did you not know but you didn't
know what you didn't know
we conceive of God as being more at the
distance between God and human beings is
far greater than the distance between a
two-year-old and a 15 year old
so when we speak about God we have to
acknowledge how limited we really are
so okay you laid out a lot of
fascinating things on the table so one
the know ability of God then this idea
of deep feeling
which again can can God be
operating the space of feelings too so
not just the mouth and the ear of the
senses can uh God be known can God be
felt by this three-year-old in the
analogy uh versus the the teenager so I
will take refuge in a beautiful phrase
by from Martin boober another Jewish
Theologian he said God cannot be
expressed God can only be addressed
in other words you can speak to God you
can feel a sense of God but can you
begin to comprehend or know God no
Joseph Cosby I'm pulling in a couple of
uh early Jewish philosophers he said to
know God I would have to be God
but can we get close is it useful or is
it a distraction to visualize things to
embody to create to the uh to attach to
the stories some kind of visualizations
in our mind uh for example gender he
versus she right things like this or old
man in the sky kind of feeling
so it's almost inevitable but I think
ultimately you try to transcend it
um this was OB this was the great you
know we just read this actually in
synagogue the story of the golden calf
and the uh the story is that human
beings found it impossible to not have a
visualization because they had just come
from Egypt and in paid in the world of
of uh Pagan worship everything is it's
not that pagans thought that Idol was
actually God but it represented visually
what God was and Along Comes this idea
that God is actually not capable of
being visualized which is very difficult
and it stretches the bounds of human
comprehension maybe even breaks them so
would you say the the proper way to
operate as a human in relation to God is
humility and that you're screwed you're
not able to basically know anything
almost anything
well the reason that you're the
salvation of this is that you can't that
you can't I was going to say the reason
you're not screwed but then I thought
somebody might be upset at a rabbi
saying that so I'm so I didn't say it
and have not said it yes um but but the
uh the the reason you're not is that you
don't have to have a comprehension of
God you have to have a relationship to
God and those are not the same I mean to
draw a a an analogy that is not up far
from perfect as most analogies are but
this one especially
you have relationships with people who
are Mysteries to you your Mysteries to
your mystery to yourself
um you can live and love somebody for 50
years and they can say something that
surprises you because ultimately we are
trapped in here and when a child first
says I we call that individuation but
what that really means is
I I now know that I am cut off from the
minds of all other
children and all other people
and
so you have with God a more intimate
relationship because you can believe
that God is
you are known by God and you have a
relationship to God despite the fact
that you can't know God just as you
can't know others
and some would say to have a good
relationship you want to be constantly
surprised right you don't want to know
the thing well the world yes the world
that God created is constantly
surprising but and by the way the the
caveat to this you know when I I had all
these debates with Christopher Hitchens
and he would always say that God is a
greater Tyrant than North Korea because
it continues after your death and the
idea of being known by God is after all
frightening if you think God knows what
I think and so on
um if your image of God is unloving